how important is it for the antagonist
to be unsympathetic well in
my kind of balancing out of the forces
in a story they have to be wildly
unsympathetic but they have to believe
that they're sympathetic right this is
so it's a it's a bit of a distinction
it's not even a subtle distinction right
they they believe that they're the hero
of Their Own Story
so they maybe go I misunderstood I'm
doing something for the greater good and
just you people are too stupid to
realize that
um but they come off as
wildly unsympathetic as a result of it I
mean you want your bad guy I mean
stories
feel to me like they have to deal in
extremes because otherwise why are we
watching it like like oh look it's a
family that's you know sitting together
and they have polite conversation around
the dinner table or you know it's like
that's going to be far less interesting
than who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf you
know where it's just fireworks from you
know from these two families you know
these two couples you know for two hours
right so it's like that's why I think
why stories exist is to live in the
extremes to make you
feel things that you wouldn't have felt
in your normal life so that when things
do happen in your normal life you are
somehow
you've experienced it so you're somehow
better able to cope with it there's this
book called uses of Enchantment by Bruno
bettelheim which looked at fairy tales
and and sort of the purposes of fairy
tales and a lot of the the whole history
of fairy tales was designed as horrible
stories that you told your kids because
the world was an incredibly scary place
so by by telling these stories it would
prepare kids for these potentially
catastrophic things that were inevitably
going to happen so things like
um
like what's it like a Little Red Riding
Hood where
you know she gets into bed with the wolf
you know and it's the Red Cloak I mean
it's it's all about losing one's
virginity you know others according to
Bruno bettelheim you know in in uses of
Enchantment and even things like like
you know like nursery rhymes you know
um you know ashes ashes We All Fall Down
that was because of the black plague you
know that the the ashes were from the
burning bodies you know and we all fall
down you know it's because they thought
that the plague was maybe carried by Ash
and smoke and stuff so it was like you
know so so stories had this had this
purpose of
and even Aristotle talked about it to
create within you these very extreme
emotions so that you felt like you went
through that so that at some point in
your life
if you're faced with a challenge similar
to what you've experienced by watching a
well-told story
um you are somehow you've got some
emotional inoculation against against
being devastated by these horrible
things that happen because you've kind
of experienced it through somebody else
somebody else's Journey meaning your the
character in a story which is another
reason why
you go back to the idea of a sympathetic
character because if I'm going to learn
the the lesson in the extreme from a
character I have to
sympathize with that character or
empathize with that character I have to
feel that character very deeply and that
will benefit me as just a human being
because I I've now experienced that
emotion from that story more completely
which if we go by the the Bruno
battleheim aristotillion version of the
purpose of story makes me a better human
or a human better able to cope with
challenges in my life so I mean so to me
like storytelling is such a noble
purpose if you look at it that way
um
you know that the this whole idea that
um
you know that
you you need the sympathetic character
and the Really unsympathetic main
character so you can experience
life at the most extreme edges rather
than the top of the bell curve where you
know everything is kind of fine and
normal right you want to feel the you
know the exhilaration of the of a
sympathetic character
overcoming challenges and you and you
want to feel the danger and the the the
tension
um of a
unrelenting very unsympathetic
antagonist at The Other Extreme so
because that's going to make the victory
that much better you know and then
therefore the emotional connection that
much better and therefore my ability to
cope with things as a human being
emotionally that much stronger so yeah
so to have like sort of characters that
are straddling the fence it could be a
perfectly fine story but it to me it
doesn't fully satisfy that sort of noble
purpose of Storytelling
unless they drastically change let's say
drastically you want to end right yeah
but you still right but you still want
to have but but yeah be careful with
those drastic changes because you know
you don't want it to feel artificial
right that you know you you you know
look I think we all
there's a balance between compassion and
Justice and you want
you know if you've got like a really bad
villain
do you want them to see the light or do
you want them to have the snot kicked
out of them right so it's challenging as
a human being because as a human being
you say hell you know look you have to
love people we have to have right but
you know if if we're going to tell the
fictionalized story of Hitler do we want
the big climax to Hitler you know for
Hitler going oh my god I've been wrong
all this time I'm so sorry you know
Hitler goes on his apology tour and he
really feels badly and he starts
adopting orphans and he's just the best
damn
we have stepfather adoptive father
you've ever
no I want I want him dead I want you
know he needs to be punished for what he
did right so and I don't think that it's
indicative of a faulty Humanity to want
to see really bad people brought to
Justice and even if that Justice Means
having this not kicked out of him
you know I was just thinking just Tom
Hanks has almost always played a
sympathetic character except in Elvis I
don't know there might be other ones
Elvis He was definitely a darker
character wrote to Perdition oh okay
okay there you go yeah
um and and it's it's on the top of my
head because it's it's famously so few
roles right almost Harry Fonda I mean
everybody lost their minds when he
played the the psychopathic villain in
Once Upon a Time in the West okay right
because Henry Fonda was On Golden Pond
yeah yeah you know he was like he was
the every man yeah he was like Tony he's
like the Jimmy Stewart you know it's
just this right you know everybody loves
you know he's just this yeah and then he
takes this role as truly the psych of
Frank I think was a character's name is
psychopathic wow you know villain you
know but what's interesting is that like
like had you cast Adolf Hitler in that
role you'd go yeah yeah we expect that
you cast Henry Fonda and suddenly it's
emotionally much more driven because you
have such an association with Henry
Fonda as everybody's dad sure right sure
it's like it's the Fall From Grace is
you know you drop something from an inch
it doesn't make much of a noise you drop
something from you know 10 feet and it
makes it big you know effect has a big
thunk so that's the thing with these
characters you know it's like they play
against type sometimes what is the
biggest mistake you see writers make
with the antagonist
I think the biggest mistake I I see
often with the antagonist is that the
antagonist is not
committed
to their goal like they they want their
goal but they're not committed to it
um and the way the way to become
committed to it is to believe 100
percent in the correctness
of the goal so so you can have a car you
can have an antagonist who is you know
driven to do
things but but if it just feels like
they're doing it because they have
nothing else going on or they they have
to be really like really committed to it
really wanting it I mean like going back
to Star Wars you know the like the you
know the emperor is the ultimate
antagonist he believes he's not just
being evil for the sake of being evil
he's he thinks he's bringing peace and
order to the uh to the to the Galaxy
like without his agenda you know it's
he's like he's the ultimate believer and
you got to break a few eggs if you want
to make an omelet you know if he doesn't
if he doesn't do what he's going to do
the entire universe will fall into into
you know some sort of
state of you know of total chaos you
know where he says okay look you know
maybe I have gotta I've got to destroy a
couple of planets to achieve my my goal
but if I don't even more planets will
get destroyed because there'll be such
chaos you know you know it needs like a
firm hand you know on the uh you know on
you know ruling the universe so so he
has to believe that yeah yeah people are
not going to like my methods but now but
give it some time and people will right
and that's just one example of a you
know of a uh of a character that was
what's so interesting about
um about Joker going back to Dark Knight
was that
was that
he can he was just representative of
chaos and and he knew he was
representative of chaos and the
brilliant part of the storytelling there
was that everybody else was trying to
figure out what is it that he's
committed to everybody understands
storytelling like in in Gotham City you
know when trying to look at the Joker
everybody is like well you can't he's
he's they're not actually having this
conversation it's like well he's clearly
the antagonist of our life right now
what is he really committed to what does
he really want we have to be able to
negotiate with him or or talk to him or
or yeah well how do and and you know and
he he fledged or you know brilliantly
it's like he goes do I look like I have
a plan he goes like I'm I'm like a dog
chasing a car I wouldn't know what to do
with it if I caught it right but
everybody else is is trying to you know
to scribe some kind of agenda to him
because they know that your antagonist
is supposed to be really committed to
something he's not he's just committed
to chaos right so if it is kind of
fascinating stuff you know as far as
like trying to look at it you know like
what do people really want
it seems like especially in the Joaquin
Phoenix version of The Joker he was
really committed to fixing the
Brokenness in himself but he didn't even
know it was fixing it he's trying to
alleviate the pain I guess in some sense
yeah not to excuse what he did but he
was so broken and so misunderstood and
so that seemed to be what his choices
were all based on right yeah for sure
it's be interesting that you know they
just announced the
um you know the Joker Sequel and it's
coming out you know you know Folia do I
think it's called which is kind of like
cool so it's going to be him and and
Harley Quinn who's not going to be
Margot Robbie
um who did they just cast this uh Harley
Quinn but yeah people were kind of like
oh it's a different take on it all but
was but but Joker is an interesting
case because because I'm not convinced
and not just me I think a lot of people
are not quite convinced that the entire
story of Joker isn't taking place in his
own head like in the Asylum so in that
in that kind if if that's the conceit
um
then
you know kind of it's almost like all
all rules are off but I think but I
think you're right I mean in at least
the Joker's mental version if it is
indeed just all taking place in his in
his own mind
um then yeah he's very broken and is
trying to cope with being broken in the
best way possible you know and find
Value in himself for you know for that
you know hence the whole like story with
you know with um you know the the woman
you know lives in the apartment and her
kid and you know so it's um yeah but
it's an interesting definitely an
interesting and sympathetic right he is
the main character yeah it's like you
see you know it's
you know proverbial undeserved
Misfortune right all the stuff bad that
happens to him he does not deserve to
happen and sympathetic is like he's
takes care of his elderly mother and you
know it's very sweet with her and washes
her hair you know so it's like but
he's the villain